I'd like to introduce grant Schellenberg
as our next speaker grant welcome to
Vancouver grant is an Associate Fellow
of CFR's program in social interactions
identity and well-being and he's the
acting director of the social analysis
division at statistics canada where he
leads analytical programs in the area of
immigration labor market adjustment
pensions and retirement and well-being
grant is also involved with several
projects at stats canada on subjective
well-being such as the life satisfaction
of recent immigrants the relationship
between life satisfaction and
neighborhood income and an assessment of
life satisfaction responses across
different stats Canada's surveys and
survey years and we're going to learn a
little bit more about that in a moment I
think he set the cat among the pigeons a
couple of days ago didn't you prior
prior to joining SATs Canada in 2003
grant was the director of work networks
at the CP RN or the Canadian Policy
Research Network grant welcome
great thank you so much for coming out
and thank you so much for for having me
on such an esteemed panel the core of
statistics canada's mandate is to
provide high quality information on
issues that matter to Canadians and what
would matter more to Canadians than
their than their well-being and my
primary objective this afternoon is to
draw your attention to the rich and
growing evidence base that we have on
subjective well-being here in Canada and
to provide one example on how this
increasingly rich and growing evidence
base can be used to further our
understanding of well-being in Canada I
pleased to say the stats can first
collected information on subjective
well-being and specifically the extent
to which people are satisfied with their
lives an evaluative component of
well-being and we included on the
general social survey back in 1985 but
since 2003 life satisfaction has been
included on surveys in a more concerted
way and the evidence base has grown
quite quickly in the last while so since
2003 we've asked a similar life
satisfaction question on the general
social survey or what I'll refer to as
the GSS and since 2009 we've been asking
the same question on the Canadian
community health survey which I'll refer
to as the cchs the GSS is an annual
survey of approximately fifteen to
twenty five thousand respondents and
each year the GSS psycho collects
information on a thematic topic such as
time use victimization family in 2013 it
was on social belonging and social
identity and the cchs is an annual
survey of 65,000 respondents that
collects information on various health
issues on both of those surveys for the
years i've shown up there we ask this
question using a scale of 0 to 10 where
0 means very dissatisfied and 10 means
very satisfied how do you feel about
your life as a whole
right now and this is the evaluative
component we're not asking about people
how happy they feel at that point in
time but we're asking them to evaluate
it in a more abstract sense if you wish
now the availability of these this
question across this wide range of
surveys allows us to do a couple of
things the first thing that allowed us
to do was to compare the life
satisfaction question across a broad
range of survey context to see how
people respond to the question was the
question volatile the people seem to get
it does it depend a lot on what the
context and on what we're asking them
and are the cove area to the factors
that are related to life satisfaction
consistent across surveys and over time
and so we did some work on this and what
we discovered was survey respondents are
able and willing to answer the life
satisfaction question very few people
refuse or say they don't know or leave
it blank there was a few small changes
on the life satisfaction question since
2003 but those had a minimal impact on
overall response patterns when we use
the GSS time use survey and we knew
exactly what day and one month and so on
that people completed this survey we
found that the life satisfaction
responses are not at all correlated with
the day of the week that people
completed the survey or the month of the
year in which they completed the survey
and we see very high level of
consistency in responses across the cchs
that is the canadian community health
serving with its consistent survey
context but greater variability across
the general social survey and we see
that this is a this is correlated with
the other types of content that's in
there and importantly we also see that
the direction and the magnitude of the
relationships between socioeconomic
characteristics like being unemployed or
having a higher or lower income or age
or education or marital status are very
consistent across these surveys so the
long and the short of this is it games
gives us a great deal of confidence in
what we're measuring has validity and is
meaningful to people and this is very
consistent with the broad literature in
the academic world as
well the other thing that having all of
these surveys and these questions on
these various surveys and survey years
is it allows us to pool the data into
into group it and what this does is it
provides very large sample sizes that
any single survey would not allow to
address questions that any single survey
would not allow us to address so for
this study that I'm going to turn to in
a moment we used the three or four
cycles or so of the of the cchs and I
think five cycles with GSS and it gave
us a pooled sample of almost three
hundred and forty thousand Canadians
over the period from 2009 to 2013 and as
the side will be able to add another
130,000 people to that sample in a few
months from now so we've got a
tremendous depth here by which we can
look at Canadian society and this is
very this is very useful so what are the
responses of these individuals look like
simple distribution here what we see is
that average life satisfaction in Canada
is just a hair under eight point Oh 8.0
out of the scale of 10 and there are
there no thresholds above or below which
someone is deemed to be satisfied or
dissatisfied with their life but what we
see here is that thirty-eight percent of
Canadians score and nine or ten on the
scale and seventy percent score an eight
nine or ten so generally people are
quite satisfied in Canada and that's
certainly consistent with the world
happiness report where Canada ranks
quite high on an international standing
if we look at the lower end of the scale
about fourteen percent of Canadians are
about one in seven have a life
satisfaction score of six or less now
with that backdrop in mind let's take a
look across cities and what we're using
here is the statscan concept of the
census metropolitan area which is the
urban area of Vancouver or wherever so
what we see here is average life
satisfaction and get just coming back
not to get too hung up on sample size
here but in Vancouver we have 17,000
respond
London's who completed this question
over that time period in Toronto we had
30,000 respondents so again very robust
estimates here so in the midpoint we see
Canada with an average life satisfaction
of just under eight point 0 and the
green bars above are the census
metropolitan areas that have life
satisfaction that's significantly higher
compared to the Canadian average and
you'll notice these these whisker plots
here this is the ninety-five percent
confidence interval so there's there's
error around these estimates so in
Calgary for example the estimate could
be this is the real estimate here or
what we observe it could be as low as
this or it could be as high as that so
it gives you some sense of what's the
magnitude of error and for some very
small CMA such as abbotsford you see
that this confidence interval is a
little bit wider so if we're going to
compare say Kelowna and Montreal while
you see there's an overlapping there so
don't make too much of this small
difference so what do we see saggin a
toile riviere st. John's Greater Sudbury
Quebec many sea mas consistently quite
higher up at around eight point two on
our ten point scale down towards the
bottom the orange bars are those that
are statistically significant from the
canadian average so toronto vancouver
windsor with average life satisfaction
scores around 7.8 now what do we want to
make about this degree of magnitude I
think the first important point to be
made here is when we compare life
satisfaction across countries of the
world the range of difference is about
10 times bigger than what we see across
these 33 census metropolitan areas so
this is a very constrained distribution
relative to the international context
but nonetheless we have of almost a
point 45 spread between the lowest and
the highest CMA on life satisfaction and
when we look at marital status or
unemployment status that's a similar
coefficient to what we're seeing across
across that and I'll come back to that
in a moment now averages tell us one
thing but let's look at some
specific spots along the distribution
this chart shows the percent of
individuals rating their life
satisfaction as a 9 or a 10 I've used
the nine and the 10 in quite an
arbitrary way and what we see here is
you know again at the top we've got
upwards of forty to forty-five percent
of Canadians in these specific sea mas
with a nine or ten on their life
satisfaction down to less than thirty
five percent in Toronto Vancouver Barry
Edmonton so overall approximately a
11-point percentage point difference in
the share of Canadians across sea mas
who are at the high end if we broaden
this and say okay well what about those
guys who scored eight they're pretty
happy too well if we look at that in who
scored eight nine or ten and we have a
14 percentage point difference across
census metropolitan areas at the other
end of the scale we saw earlier about
fourteen percent of people score six or
less on the life satisfaction scale and
again saggin a Quebec 12 year that share
is less than ten percent and again
abbotsford Toronto and Windsor upwards
of sixteen to seventeen percent of of
individuals ranking their life
satisfaction as six or below now the
objective of this study was not the
document and explain the broad range or
to explain the variance across sea mas
but rather to highlight the fact that
these differences are there but
nonetheless what factors might explain
these differences that we could at least
start to address this so it may be the
case and I'll come to this in just a
minute it may be the case that there's
more unemployed folks in a certain CMA
or there's more immigrants in Vancouver
and Toronto than there are in the saggin
a or that household incomes might vary
across the sea mas and it might be that
the the cumulative effect of the
characteristics of the individuals in
these
gmas are indeed what account for the
differences that we're observing so what
we did is we ran some statistical
analysis and what this shows is how much
relative to the reference group specific
characteristic and I've just selected
some here how much specific
characteristics are associated with
differences in life satisfaction so
women are slightly more happy or more
satisfied with their life than men
immigrants slightly less compared to
individuals who are married the
coefficient for individuals who are
separated or divorced their minus point
6 on that 10-point scale or those who
are widowed or about a minus 4.6 on that
scale compared to individuals who are
employed the unemployed have a negative
employment has a negative effect of
about point 5 and similarly you see the
impact here for household differences
across household income relative to
those who have a household income of 100
to 150 thousand and again you see the
the strong correlation was self assess
health now if we take all of these
characteristics into account how much of
the difference across census
metropolitan areas remain well in fact
most of it about 85 to 90 percent so a
very small share is actually explained
by these individual level
characteristics the other thing that
might come to mind is Toronto and
Vancouver certainly are at the bottom of
that distribution so maybe it's strictly
an urban size effect that large cities
are that have something to do with
negative impact on life satisfaction so
what I'm showing in this last slide here
is we've done two things we've adjusted
for individual level socio economic
characteristics as I've mentioned and we
just did a simple categorization for
cmas that have less than 250 thousand
two hundred and fifty thousand to a
million and then large sea mas so even
there we see Toronto with life's this is
the percent scoring eight nine and ten
so about sixty-five percent of the
residents of Toronto after adjusting for
individual level characteristics score
an 89
10 compared to 71 or 72 percent in
Montreal if we look across small CMA
certainly I think there is through a
there's a size effect but I think what's
striking here is again controlling for
these characteristics places like Barry
and Guelph the percent you know around
65 66 percent of individual scoring in
eight nine or ten again with the
adjustment compared to over seventy five
percent of some of the Quebec sea mas so
quite clearly there's considerable
variation here so looking ahead I guess
my key point to be made here is that
information on life satisfaction is
increasingly deep and rich that our
cumulative sample of respondents that we
have in these surveys continues to grow
and that we could get both wrote more
robust estimates for the cmas we've
shown here and we also have scope to
disaggregate these census metropolitan
areas into smaller geographies with the
addition of the the sample I mentioned
coming up we'll have 20 22 24 thousand
responses for Vancouver alone so if we
want to look at Richmond you know Port
Coquitlam west van and so on we could
start to dig deeper and as we do that
across CMAs it gives us more more units
of analysis to look at it we can extend
our analysis the other thing that's
happening is the range of
characteristics or covariance that we
have for examining life satisfaction of
individuals continues to increase so we
hear that there's a lot that that the
importance of identity or social
belonging of participation of people's
ties with others is an important coral
or determinant of life satisfaction so
with the survey like the GSS on social
identity we can dig much deeper into
that and as we get recruit repeated as
we get cross-sectional files over time
that we do have increasing scope to
track life satisfaction over time among
specific groups for identifying broad
trends and there's been some work in
Canada suggesting or showing
a large increase in life satisfaction in
the province of Quebec relative to the
rest of Canada and as we as we have data
from two thousand onward we already got
a we have a span of 12 years it won't be
long before we left 20 years of data to
track those trends nonetheless I think
building on the previous studies to
identify the factors accounting for
inter cma differences in life
satisfaction is there still a tremendous
amount of work to be done but I think we
are fortunate in Canada that we have a
rich database and rich information to
bring statistical information to the
qualitative work that we see at the
ground level as well and it's the
combination of those two things that I
think is particularly powerful so thank
you very much thanks grant look forward
to hearing the questions from the
audience 44 in comments for the two of
you and for our next guest and by the
way in terms of interaction questions
comments exploration of some of the
things that you're doing all of that is
welcome and we can do it in a couple of
ways we're going to have mics move
around the audience or you can come up
front here and ask the question and have
a little bit of a dialogue with with our
panelists